[Music]
hello hello everybody thank you for
coming my name is Lexie and this is
DevOps in a serverless world
I work as a developer advocate at Google
in the cloud organization and before we
get started let me tell you about the
tool that we have to take questions
hopefully we'll have some time for
questions towards the end in the app in
the conference app there's a section for
this talk where you can ask questions
you can even see other people's
questions and you could vote them up or
I think even down if you'd like I hope
we have time for this if we don't I will
and and my colleagues will provide
answers right in the tool so with that
out of the way I do need to spend just a
little bit of time defining service one
of the buzz words in the title that I
used is service and I really believe
that there's real and profound reasons
why you would want to use service today
when writing new applications or maybe
even taking existing applications to the
cloud from an operational model there
are no servers to provision no cluster
to set up no cluster to administer or
secure and the important thing is that
you are billed for the actual usage via
optimized and transparent auto-scaling
that's the operational model from a
developer's perspective this is really
focused on being consuming and exposing
services it's a very service focused
environment you're also reacting and
producing events the loose coupling
between your modules between your
services is probably done through
venting and finally we'd like as
developers probably to have an
environment that's open as possible so
we're not locked in to any particular
solution now let's go back to the word
service the many jokes are about service
yes there are servers this is not
Google's new and latest service data
center but there's sometimes some
confusion
it's kind of weird to define an area by
what it's not you know circle s so let
me suggest that we try to find a new
word a better word how about no ops I
mean this is trying this term is trying
to capture the fact that developers can
focus on delivering great apps and focus
on code rather than on the
infrastructure so who thinks here this
is a good better approach than surplice
a few hands okay I think I think I liked
it before I really realize that this is
not a whole lot better well first of all
here's another term that's defining
something by what it is not but actually
if you consider operations as the
practice of keeping the tak that runs
your business going then no ops is not
really good term so implying that
operations is something that might go
away or is something that you don't need
is I think a misunderstanding of ops in
general and maybe DevOps in particular
so I'm sorry I don't have a better term
so we're stuck with with serverless what
I do have for you is some of the best
practices we've developed at Google over
the years and but before we get into
that let's talk about the challenges
specifically in the context of service
when it has to do with managing those
service workloads and what makes it a
bit trickier than other workloads
well first by definition you don't have
access to the server's you cannot
install your favorite agent on the
machines to you know talk call home to
some administration or to some service
providing monitoring there is no SS
aging into the machine and that's a good
thing we will don't want you to log into
this machine and start creating
snowflakes the second thing is that this
is an environment that has multiple
services interacting with one another or
with service buses or through messages
and micro services are great because you
can operate or scale each service
independently but tracing calls through
the system can be both more more
critical and trickier to actually
achieve and things like cascading
failures become a lot harder to diagnose
third cloud and service work really best
when auto scaling is implemented and
auto scaling is all about spinning up
instances to take the load but also
taking them down so we save on cost and
that's great but that increases the
overall systems entropy and makes
monitoring somewhat more complicated
because the system keeps on changing
shape and finally service compute
workloads often event triggered so the
asynchronous nature of events makes it
more complex to understand how an
application got into a certain state so
we do have a number of challenges here
specific to service when it comes to
monitoring managing your environment now
let me take a moment to go through the
GCP service compute options to get
everyone on the same page first of all
we have cloud functions
this is functions as a service where you
deploy shorts amount of code a list of
dependencies and the event that triggers
this code to run we have App Engine
which is more suited for front-end
applications with multiple services
multiple modules and this one comes with
built-in versioning and traffic
splitting and finally in you if you'd
rather have the flexibility and the
freedom of container based applications
where you can choose your stack anything
you'd like anything you'd like to put in
that container and still want the
service benefits well then cloud run is
the new product we're announcing today
that has several sessions that will go
into the details of this but we will
dive a little bit into it and certainly
do a little demo of monitoring cloud run
so cloud functions is really there to
react to events and those events can be
as simple as HTTP requests but they can
be also uploads to a bucket messages
posted to pub/sub topic they could be
data changing in fire store they could
be metadata changing in a object in
cloud storage and there are many more
coming it has all the surveillance
qualities this cost a second ago and it
offers a choice of runtimes and as you
might see here we're adding new modern
runtimes updating existing ones and
adding new ones in particular here we're
announcing this week the support for
Java 8 for functions App Engine as I
mentioned has been around for a little
while and is a solution to deploy code
as well and have the cloud scale the
application for you based on the load
there are no clusters to setup or manage
and it comes with traffic splitting
multiple versions of your app and it
offers a wide variety of runtimes as
well this week we're announcing Ruby 2.5
as a new support runtime and there's a
dedicated session for that and there
should be links to those later in this
presentation and as announced earlier
this morning we also now have this thing
called cloud run a fully managed compute
platform that enables you to run
stateless containers that are in vocable
via HTTP requests cloud run is service
which means it attracts away all
infrastructure all infrastructure
management so you can focus on building
great apps with any technology stack
you'd like it is built with key native
letting you choose your containers from
either a fully managed cloud run or a
google kubernetes engine cluster with
cloud run on gke so if you're still
confused about the various options we
have to offer think of it this way
you can think of it in terms of which
artifact you'd like to give us and to
run in this herbalist fashion if it's a
function or a collection of functions
well cloud function clearly is the
option that you should look at if you'd
like to provide something that's more
granular that has multiple modules that
have dependencies well consider App
Engine because what you're giving us is
really an app and if you'd like to give
us a container because you want total
freedom in terms of what you're using
inside that container
well cloud run now becomes an amazingly
interesting option let me just mention
to add to the server list compute
picture cloud pub/sub cloud task and
cloud scheduler these offer very elegant
solutions to actually use multiple
products together if you'd like to
orchestrate several functions or have
different parts being built from in your
application using those different
technologies now let's go back here to
cloud functions and let's get into a
small demo and see in a DevOps and
tribulus topic of this talk how you can
actually have a logging set of features
to enable you to see what's going on in
a service and a cloud function
application so here let me go back this
is cloud console and this is an
application in which I can choose from a
set of pictures and I can say hello
next attendees and what this will do is
post a message to pop sub to which for
different functions written and for
different languages will react and
manipulate that image by adding logos
and the text that I just entered now if
you look at the backend of those and you
look at the console everything here is
written with cloud functions we have a
few helper functions and we have one
that processes the image in the go
language another one in Java
in node and one in Python so if I look
at let's say this cloud function I can
see in the course of 24 hours how many
invocations came in and warned that many
how much time these took on average and
I could see the various data that's here
in yet I can of course look at something
that's over the course of two days for
example and what's interesting here is
that I can get to the logs of that
specific function I can see all the logs
aggregated here I might have multiple
instances of this running this might be
running on physical different servers I
really don't have to care this is a
unified consolidated fully managed view
of the environment I can filter by log
level in this case we only have two
which are info typically the things that
I put out in the standard output and the
system events which are you know the
function completed this is how long it
took or the function started and and
these are cloud function events now what
I can do here is look at this guy which
is what we call the execution ID and I
would like to show all the matching
entries so every log for this function
the node function and which has this
execution ID so typically this is one
request for node so I could see the
entire process starting with the
function starting you know the request
ID then the name of the file the output
file downloading files from compute
storage processing the image using
imagemagick to do the transformation and
eventually storing the new image and
finishing now that's really nice you
could see here the filter that was
populated for me
maybe maybe what I would like to do at
this point is remove the fact that I'm
looking at this node feature and this
node function and actually look at all
the ones that have this specific
execution ID
so I could see that for one event I have
a node which we just saw function
executing a note an a go function a Java
function as well as a Python function
and if I take this one little step
further I can also see things such as
how long they took so if I add this
execution took had additional filter
here I could see that indeed I had five
functions and they took anywhere between
a few hundred milliseconds to a few
seconds so that's a quick here demo of
what you can expect in cloth functions
when it comes to logging of course
there's way more to to logging into
DevOps than just log in and we'll get
into that in a second oh and this demo
is available on the show floor if you'd
like to play with it and understand and
talk into greater details and about how
it was built
now I said that I did not have a better
term than service but what I do have is
some DevOps lessons learned from Google
that have recently materialized under
the name s re so SR e stands for site
reliability engineering and in fact you
can state the following and the
developers in the room will understand
this s re
implements DevOps essary is really an
opinionated implementation of DevOps
there are other valid implementations of
DevOps principles Google just uses SRA
when you say DevOps we really think s re
in fact the industry seems to have
adopted s re as a term and companies
such as Microsoft Apple Twitter Facebook
Dropbox Amazon and others all have s re
teams that they call that way so let's
dive into this and see what we leaders
behind this acronym at Google we deliver
services to billions of users and if you
look at those services
they're really managed by a fairly small
set of a saris
we have multiple products that serve
billion or more users each and all of
them have you know a few a series and if
you do the math that's hundreds of
thousands of users for single sree and
if you've ever carried a pager and been
in the ops world this is very different
you cannot you know be pulled into
hundreds or thousands or tens or
hundreds of thousands of directions
trying to put out fires between between
the different projects that you that you
manage instead the SRA model can keep
your users happy your business running
without blowing your operations budget
you cannot scale the number of sres
with the number of users that you have
or or else you would be burning out a
small group of people or you'd be
relying on some heroic individual
actions which is really not the point of
masari's so s Ari's really at the end of
the day try to balance two competing
needs
the first one is reliability it's my
service available is it returning 200
errors error codes or is it three four
or five errors second agility you can
make something almost perfectly stable
if you never allow changes but Google is
really about experimenting speed and
innovation so how do s eries balance
both needs and keep their sanity so the
answer lies really in an iceberg it all
starts with the culture there are a
number of books that have written didn't
written by Googlers and I encourage you
to read those just just google them
they're available online they're also
available from O'Reilly the goal of an
SRE is really to automate him or herself
out of the job
the engineering reliability needs to be
built into the product and those are
sarees participate in the development of
the product and in particular they try
to make
things as observable as possible one
important thing to note here is that
they can refuse to carry the pager
because they consider the app or the
service to not be well instrumented sre
is also responsible for on calls but
also for things like blameless post
mortems which is really an important
part of the asari culture but also
things like incident management testing
see ICD continuous integration
continuous deployment the other part
here is that's really important is the
infrastructure as sarees are completely
outnumbered by software engineers so
opinionated infrastructure is the only
approach every service needs to have a
name to be discoverable to have quota to
have permissions and it needs to come
with base telemetry in no matter why so
that platform that infrastructure here
brings observability it captures the
data typically in a time-series database
and it makes it available for querying
and from running analysis now there are
a number of open-source projects we
contribute to but what we use and we
expose to Google cloud platform users is
stackdriver which is both the technology
the platform as well as the tools that
sit on top of it but really the tooling
is the tip of the iceberg and and you
really need the bottom layers for all of
this to be extremely useful now going
back to the culture aspect of a saris
rather than playing whack-a-mole all day
trying to put out fires as saris look at
what impacts customers and users
directly so this is called a service
level indicator let's like a bad example
of SLI a CPU goes to 80% that is not a
good service service level indicator it
could affect the customer but in reality
we've done the obvious thing of
implementing auto scaling so at some
point the problem just goes away so
there's no really point in paging
somebody in the middle of the night
because that CPU has hit that threshold
an SLI a service level indicator is
fairly close to what other people refer
to as keep KPIs and it really needs to
impact your customer or your business so
obvious examples of that probably better
examples are things around availability
in other words how many of my requests
are coming back with 200 response codes
and the second one is latency what
percentage of my requests come back with
responses in less than say 300
milliseconds these are two obvious ones
of course you can come up with other
things that have impact on your customer
or your business now moving on to SLO s
or service level objectives these are
promises you make to yourself at Google
S ellos are actually and this might come
as a surprise to some of you
they're never a hundred percent mostly
because this would mean you can't ever
change anything and again we try to
deploy new features try new things out
and innovate fairly quickly so the
interesting thing here is that when you
subtract the SLO from 100 you get
something we refer to as an error budget
and this is defined for a given period
of time this is critical and a key part
of s re practices managing that budget
if you burn through your budget this
means you really should stop adding new
features and rolling out new experiments
and go back and work on your technical
debt and make your system more reliable
on the other hand if you've never used
your budget that means you're not
experimenting enough so we call this a
budget for a reason we manage this as a
budget we have a budget we actually
consume that so the bottom line is that
you really want to make your service as
reliable as your customers need and
spend your arrow budget on adding new
features so when do you actually page
some
buddy in the middle of the night if you
have to well that's when your error
budget is dropping rapidly and and
that's really something you should be
monitoring
and finally SLA you know it's important
but it's really a business concept and
it's it's just the the business aspect
of SLO so it doesn't really fit into the
the s re description of things now
another best practice is versioning your
services and better than that actually
having those services multiple one of
them multiple ones of them to be active
at the same time if you're able to
deploy multiple active versions of your
services you can decide to deploy them
maybe from your promoted builds and you
can carry the build version all the way
through to deployment and in this case
you can then start doing very
interesting things such as a/b testing
may be things like cannery and Bluegreen
deployments deploying a new version to
and exposing only a small subset of you
users to it and then incrementing and
increasing the amount of users that are
exposed to it and eventually move to the
entire new version if all goes well or
roll back to a previous version so the
ability to have those versions opens up
a lot of possibilities when deploying so
that you have both flexibility and
confidence in your deployments so there
are other sessions that fall under the
sea ICD which I am not really talking
about here and I encouraging you to
attend some of these there's one today
one tomorrow and one on Thursday now
let's talk about stag driver both the
platform and the tools stack driver
really is the technology that we use and
that implements that platform that I
talked about this is where we collect of
course logs metrics of all sorts this is
where we extract errors this is where we
infer relationships this
something that we provide dashboards
with there's a bunch of tools that are
built in the stack driver offering but
there's also a set of api's that are
available for others to build upon
Google stack driver is the
externalization of googles as sorry best
practices in a way it has the the
infrastructure the platform and the
observability for GCP applications that
I've mentioned before so let's quickly
go through some of these tools and we'll
be demoing a number of these next so the
built in products you've already seen
the logging in my short demo with
centralized fully managed logs across
all products I used it to show cloud
functions but this works equally well
across App Engine and cloud run and of
course you look at all those logs
regardless of the physical location of
the application running cloud traces
takes the execution ID you saw in that
quick demo and and takes it a bit
farther by providing a view of calls
across services how much time there's a
call to cloud storage take how long is
imagemagick
taking to manipulate that image how long
is it before I can write the response to
cloud storage this is a tool that will
actually help you compare different
traces so it's a very powerful line
error reporting is probably one of my
favorites because it's really easy to
set up because there is no setup this
offers offers alerting and summaries for
application errors as you your
application generates errors 500
typically errors writes stack traces to
the output to the standard output it
will capture all of this and it will
provide you a view in which you can see
when was the first time and the last
time this error occurred how often does
it occur and of course the stack trace
so it will group those together instead
of showing you too much data and
and I think it's very useful and very
easy to to take advantage of cloud
profiler and cloud debugger really take
all of this to the next level because
they bring what is traditionally
development time tooling to production
workloads so through open source and and
minimal overhead the cloud profiler
offers CPU and memory cost analysis down
to function and Method levels a cloud
debugger lets you inspect the state of a
running application with live snapshots
and it even lets you add log statements
without a redeploy so how often have you
redeployed just to add a lock statement
well if you use cloud debugger you
probably will not have to do this again
and we'll see this in action in a short
moment so stackdriver
also exposes data with api's so one can
use this to build for example SLO
monitoring dashboards which are really
important because this is where it all
starts then you need to have the tools
to drill in to understand what the
problem is but the monitoring of your
SLO is probably where it all starts so
speaking of exposing metrics via the
stack driver API I would like now to
introduce Daniel Langer from data dog to
talk about the integration they've done
with our new release product cloud run
over to you they know cool Thank You
Alexi so like Alexi just said my name is
Daniel I'm a I'm a product manager at
data dog and really quick for those of
you who don't know what data dog is
we're a monitoring platform so we
collect infrastructure metrics traces
and application level metrics logs we
centralize it in one SAS platform let
you create alerts dashboards do cause
analysis we're an Operations tool to
make sure that everything in your
environment is running smoothly we have
an open-source agent and over 250
integrations and an open API so that no
matter where you're running what you're
running you can monitor it within data
dog we are over seven
seven 7,500 customers were processing
trillions of data points a day so we've
got some scale behind us we've been on a
partner with Google cloud for many years
now and we have tons of different
integrations so whatever you're running
in Google Cloud
you can monitor it in data dog so we
collect metrics right via stackdriver
and other sources and today we are
excited to announce a brand new
integration with stack driver logs so
that whatever logs are generating that
are being stored in stack driver you can
now view them in data dog what's more
with the announcement of Google cloud
run today
you can both send metrics and logs from
that service into data dog as well like
I mentioned we also have an agent all
right this open source program that you
can deploy where you have servers
running if you're running compute engine
or GK you can deploy the data dog agent
right onto those to get insights into
custom metrics traces and logs as well
so really exciting cloud run came out
today so I want to do a quick demo of
how you can monitor this within data dog
so I've set up a pretty simple cloud run
service with I've had a couple revisions
going in this example I hated a low
amount of memory a low amount of
concurrency you know just to get it
going behind the scenes is a super
simple flask app right I have a couple
routes I've set up a hello world route a
/ Daniel rocks route and then a route
that's gonna eat up the memory of this
of this cloud run service so super
simple and if we go over to my terminal
we can see that I have a script running
that's hitting the the hello world and
the Daniell route it's running smoothly
it's fetching over and over again nice
and smooth and if we pop on over to data
dog I want to show you a couple things
so what this is is a data dog time board
where you can drag and drop widgets from
and plot metrics and information across
your entire infrastructure and in this
one we have a few things you can see
that we have 200 responses for this
revision everything is looking nice our
latency is smooth and our CPU and memory
allocation are pretty constant as well
right so the as is running you can see
that the service is is performing nicely
but let's throw let's throw a wrench
into that so let's go back to terminal
and let's run this eat memory script
that's gonna hit that that that other
endpoint and as we can see it's now
spitting out that we're out of memory
this is a this is a print statement that
I that I actually made and we hop on
over back to my other script we can see
it's acting up as well right hitting
this new endpoint that's eating up
memory is is causing things to get a
little funky so if we hop on back hop on
back over to to data dog and we take a
look at our updated dashboard we can see
this in data dog right the number of to
hundreds has gone down the the request
latency has gone up and in this case we
know why right I started running this
script that's hitting this out of memory
that's hitting this eat memory thing but
let's say you were you know the owner
for this service and you had no idea why
this request latency was going up you
just saw this graph or you received an
alert that latency I gone up what do you
do well this is where the power of logs
comes in and especially important to
understand the why something's happening
so what we can do is write in data dog
we can click on that spike and we can go
down to view related logs and what
that's gonna do is take us to the data
dog log Explorer scoped to that exact
time frame with the context in frame so
we can see we have a three minute window
of logs right before and after I clicked
and it's scoped to that revision that
that time series plot referred to so we
have a nice scoping here however as you
can see we still have over a thousand
log lines for those couple minutes so
it's still pretty broad but we can
quickly narrow that down we can say
let's only look at the error logs right
so we've scoped it down we only have 90
now and we could also use a feature
called patterns which will automatically
group
similar logs so that it's easy to find
needle and a hit and needles in a
haystack in this case we only have a
couple types of log so it's not super
exciting but now we can quickly see that
the cause of our issue is we're hitting
that memory right
not super exciting we knew this is why
but you know if you were a developer
trying to debug it this would be really
really vital we'll automatically parse
out important attributes from logs right
so you can easily see them create facets
search for them query for them
whatever might be important to you you
can search for them in data dog logs I
want to quickly go back to the data dog
dashboard really quick and highlight one
thing that Alexey touched on that's
really important and that is s ellos
right in SLI so this widget you see here
is called the data dog uptime widget and
it lets you track those exact things
those SLO is right in data dog so in
this example we have an application
latency that's our service level
indicator and we can see over different
time periods if we are meeting our SOS
sadly in this example it doesn't appear
that we are so alongside your metrics
and all of your you know your service
metrics application metrics you can
understand your SLO s as well so that
was just a brief foray into data dog and
what we're doing with cloud run already
we are super excited by the launch today
we expect great things and we're looking
forward to learning more as you all
begin to use it I'm gonna pass it back
on over to Alexi now thank you
Thank You Daniel for the demo thank you
for the plug for s ellos I think it's
really important to be monitoring those
s ellos that's really something that's
been working well for us and also there
was no setup on the client-side the
people writing the applications didn't
have to integrate with data dog or with
stackdriver again you know this is
something that you get for free and then
you have of course a number of tools
that you can use to to monitor things
now let's switch gears a little bit and
talk about cloud debugger and for that
let me introduce a little bit a software
engineer working on an app engine
standard who will walk you through some
demos on App Engine and cloud debugger
yep thank you Alex Lee so we'll we'll
try to do the removal of the cloud
debugger so the cloud debugger we four
to debug the Claddagh burger which is a
to run the cloud debugger in an app
engine application we will run an
application called called pica daily
which can upload well let's switch the
second laptop please so it's Piccadilly
come and you can upload a picture we
scan it and we try to find tags so here
this picture was taken last yesterday
and we can see it's a vehicle a car Road
Lane parking Street whatever okay or
borrow strawberries we we can find it
strawberries using Google cloud vision
API s so this application is the
collection of micro services the
front-end is written in Java as an app
engine application so here you see the
App Engine console with the current
service running it's running on Java 8
so these are the list of applications
that have been deployed it's a java
application you deploy it as a web app
and it would be nice if you could
look at all the logs of this application
even after this application has been
deployed okay so for that we're going to
use a tool which is fully integrated
with App Engine so if I go to the Tools
menu you have two views one is log and
one is debug so the debug view will
switch the cloud console to the Claddagh
burger which is configured for you out
of the box for all the App Engine
applications so here to debug an
application you need source code usually
and what you deploy to App Engine is a
jar file or a collection of jars and
frameworks so to make the console aware
of your source code you can either
connect your application with a cloud
source
resource cloud source repository or you
can upload you can upload a file from
your laptop the only thing we need is
source code to map to a line number of
you know in a Java file so here the App
Engine application has been connected to
a cloud repository and I can now
navigate to Java source code so you can
see we are using cloud api's for storage
we are we are using a spark Java
framework which is really cool
you can do two things with this cloudy
bugger you can set a breakpoint like you
would do on your laptop for a local
debugging and it's very interesting
because in the cloud an app engine
application can scale scale to millions
of je viens ok so which which one do you
attach a debugger to it's quite
complicated so the Clady bugger will
listen to a snapshot which are more less
breakpoints without stopping your
application and the first JVM eating
this line will capture the instead of
the memory and dump in somewhere so that
you can analyze it so it's very cool
because let's say
I want to set a breakpoint not here in
line so here we have a collection of
pictures here which is an ArrayList we
populate it so let's put a breakpoint
after so I just click on the line number
well snapshot and line number and now
the debugger is telling is waiting for
the application to be triggered
so let's reload the application Oh
somebody took a picture and now maybe
we'll see it here because in this
debugger view I can see the state of the
memory of my JVM so I can look at all
the variable request response the
pictures which is an ArrayList and the
first one that might have been taken
right away with color two minutes ago
okay so I can I can debug live my
application in production with the
Claddagh burger so you have seen in the
previous presentation or the logging
capabilities of Google Cloud it would be
nice if after you deploy your
application to inject a new log entry
point in your log viewer okay so Clara
burger can do that with what we call a
log point so instead of setting a
breakpoint to your application what you
want to do to add after deployment is an
entry in your life so here in line
184 I would type an expression which is
the content I want to add every time
this line is rich in my application so
here I can put some text pictures
okay peak equal and to put a variable
you put open brackets or pictures that
get that zero so I will I will just dump
the first picture the first entry in the
array sorry I put a typo so I can edit
it here good point
right by the typing thank you you are
debugging my debugger I apply and then
so apparently the lock point has been
entered so let's reload the application
here okay the picture if I go back to
the debugger I said the log level 2 info
so now in my log viewer in the console I
should I should find somewhere I don't
know exactly where it is but I should
find
reload yeah here by my new line in the
Lord which can be which can be now
analyzed with all the other log viewers
and stackdriver capabilities of our
integration so this is you know in few
minutes a demo of the Claddagh berger
running live in App Engine so it's
enabled by default it has zero cost it
doesn't slow down your application and
when you use it it's very handy because
we all make mistakes and we need debug
errors even in production an independent
stage thank you thank you thank you for
anything Leon the title
if we could go back to this machine
please so this this was a demo of cloud
debugger again set up for every
application that's running already in
App Engine so this was the quick demo
and thank you for participating and
posting a few pictures this is the
vision API polling data for each of
these pictures and we do have an admin
for this just just in case you know so
we can remove any pictures that were
submitted and this is the brief
architecture that we that we have put in
place that uses both functions and App
Engine and orchestrate some of that
through pub/sub and through cloud
schedule as well now this was your so
let me close out here with a few
thoughts so first of all I think a move
to service or an increase of service in
your production workloads is an amazing
opportunity to actually redefine or
define those SL eyes and SL O's I think
this is where you focus on the developer
and this is where you set really things
that matter to your business as things
that you should be monitoring the second
step probably especially given the
announcement that we've made around
cloud run is try to understand what is
the best cloud service tool for the job
if you'd like to give us functions
because functions of service is really
how you think you want to build your
applications that's that's so good and
fine maybe you'd like to have something
more granular and maybe that's an
application made of multiple app modules
and that's App Engine maybe it's a
container because you want full freedom
in terms of what languages and
frameworks you use and that would
probably be cloud run so spend a little
bit of time probably in the sessions
describing and getting into the details
of cloud run and to understand which
server list tool is best for the job
all of which come supported with logging
and monitoring and then there are
features in app engine should such as
the cloud debugger and and other
features in other products and profit so
with that let me give you a list of
related sessions there are some
interesting ones happening today there
are more tomorrow and there's more on
Thursday
some of them have to do with trying to
find and choose those best runtimes
others are more involved in to see ICD
as I mentioned earlier some are focused
on specific languages because number of
developers identifying themselves by the
language of their choice
so I would really encourage you to look
at these others that session as we are
303 which is running cloud run on an
existing gke cluster which is a very
interesting topic
I believe so with that let me pull up
our tool and see if we have any
questions and if you do have questions
we have microphones here in the aisles
and you're free to to step up to one of
them and I believe they're now open for
questions
thank you for coming and this session
will be made available online real soon
hi my name is van a quick question on
the Antos announcement today how does
this integrate with you know some of the
migration that we could do with the
hybrid cloud but that's a very good
question
we're not really so anthesis doesn't
really qualify as service because
service is probably scale to zero it has
a number of things around billing as you
go as opposed to paying for the cluster
all the time every as when it's up so if
it's kubernetes per se it's not really
service if you add key native and you
add things such as cloud run on G key on
top of it it becomes service so that's
why I didn't cover this and we didn't
cover this in this session but anthos
comes with a really advanced set of
features to monitor and and all the
things I've said about a Sarris whole
true and all the tools that they have
that are specific to JK eco probably
just as far as what we've seen here
there's a lot that comes with it and
there's a console which is really
dedicated for DevOps for anthos that
that's made available and you should
probably go in the on the ground on the
show floors or check out some sessions
there's definitely a lot to to look at
there
I my question is also about think about
integration how these things works with
Apogee and to expose those micro
services using API manager so you
thought Apogee is the energy right so
Apogee filler for a while has been
somewhat separate from Google cloud it's
all about you know enabling businesses
to to to expose their services as api's
I am NOT very familiar with Apogee to be
to be honest they have a set of tools
there's quite a bit of integration
that's going on with Apogee where
everything we've we've discovered here
everything we taught talked about I will
apply equally to Apogee in the fairly
near near future but I can't comment
very much more on the existing tools
that are available now let me I did say
that I went to check questions yes there
are a few actually so Jeff asks how do
you recommend secure securing cloud
functions that need access to GCP
resources so that's typically where we
have work going on with Apogee I think
Apogee is where the answer lies for this
because they have some fairly advanced a
gateway features that can play that role
of securing cloud functions we're also
working on making functions protected as
a base feature so you don't have to pull
in things like Apogee let me try to get
to last one how does cloud containers
relate to App Engine Flex environment it
scales to zero is the short answer if
you want more we have dedicated sessions
but for the fully managed and the cloud
run on gke solutions and with that I'm
sorry I'm told that we're out of time
but we're sticking around please come to
us if you have questions and thank you
for coming
[Music]